you
but I'm flying
it feels I think anything is possible
I am the sum of many parts i think what
you see on the screen and and and what i
would actually get to bring to the table
is incredible backup I have martin
campbell i have geoff johns I mean you
know even the one thing that Warner
Brothers does I think better than any
other studios that they actually really
spend the money on on on the right
affects people and and and bringing it
all to the screen in the way it should
be done and having grant major these
between Lord of the Rings nyla Dixon I
mean these incredible talents that are
working behind the scenes to to make
sure that this is not just a movie but
an experience that that's the thing
that's kind of blown me away
house
sits power
to defend out another the technological
challenges are not that bad it's
everybody else who has to do that in the
sense of first of all creating the
worlds of our naturally as we go deep
into the universe's unit into the
virtual world well where Hal becomes a
real Apple is trained and subsequently
battle for real and that the without the
production designer Lord of the Rings is
doing all our stuff and don't move
neighbor fantastic drop so creating
those worlds is a very time consuming
and long process and we have a lot of it
a lot takes place on earth and awful lot
of blue screens and stuff you know
hanging on ropes flapping your arms and
going through a system doing all that
stuff so all you to me that it's been
well I've done a little bit on other
films but there's basically realistic
backgrounds and so forth you know I mean
I've touched on it but never to the
success
Wow I'll oh right brightest day